hello next welcome to our breakout
session where we'll talk about the six
incredibly powerful gka capabilities you
may have missed
it's a fun session packed with cutting
edge tech and a demo of our newest
capabilities
my name is jersey and today with me it's
roman both of us are product managers on
google kubernetes engine team
together we'll learn how using gke and
adopting the right culture can help
customers like
ub a japan-based healthcare technology
startup that automatically generates
medical records using an ai powered
patient questionnaire app achieve 20
saving while deploying to hundreds of
medical institutions and improving
availability or scoop with a media
platform for whom auto scaling on gke
helps match capacity with the real-time
demand
the result is 99 uptime and 50 reduction
in infrastructure cost while removing
operational burdens now they can invest
more time on coding and less on managing
the resources as well as mr cooper
an industry-leading mortgage service
provider that now can park their nodes
to achieve 90 cpu load in fact
forester conducted a study in which they
created a composite organization based
on the gke customers and concluded the
following total economic impact numbers
of gke with expected investment payback
in under six months for a typical
customer
check their study to learn more
over to roman
thank you yeah
this is great
our team is on a critical mission a
mission to empower you the user to never
again waste time and money on
infrastructure you don't actually use
when you run workloads on google
kubernetes engine we know you've made
the choice in favor of simplicity
efficiency security and scalability but
we also know that falling for the known
efficiency pitfalls is easy when you're
in charge of running infrastructure at
scale with its endless number of
components and possibilities
in six years of gtk's existence we
learned that four major challenges make
your life hard
the first challenge is cultural
many teams that embrace the public cloud
aren't used to the pay-as-you-go billing
style and frequently don't fully
understand the environment their apps
are running on in this case kubernetes
the phenops movement which is getting
lots of attention recently is all about
evolving such a culture
one of the phenom's best practices is to
provide teams with real-time information
about their spending and their business
impact small things like this have
considerable impact on companies culture
resulting in a more balanced cost
optimization equation
the second challenge is bean packing how
well you pack applications onto your
kubernetes nodes the better you pack
apps onto nodes the more you save
then we have the upright sizing the
ability to set appropriate resource
requests and auto scale applications
deployed in the cluster the more
precisely you set resources on your pods
the more reliably your applications will
run and in the vast majority of cases
the more space you'll save in the
cluster
and the last challenge is not scaling
down your cluster during off peak hours
ideally to save money during low demand
periods for example at night your
cluster should be able to scale down
following the actual demand
however in some cases
scaling down doesn't happen as expected
due to workloads or cluster
configurations that block cluster
autoscaler
by themselves each of those are tricky
but together this is a complex problem
in our experience most of our
provisioned environments have at least
two of the following challenges at hand
but fear not we're here to help
let's look at some of the incredibly
powerful gke capabilities you might have
missed that will take you a step closer
to running gt at scale cost effectively
jersey over to you
and tell us about your favorite top
three thank you roman
i certainly have my
own top three let me focus on some of
the existing top of the line ga
capabilities
and here there are
autopilot
traditional kubernetes expects you
the user to understand and manage the
control plane worker node security
configuration upgrades scaling and
availability
gke on the other hand is a truly managed
service that helps you focus on your
business
the best and most intelligent way of
using kubernetes today is by activating
gk autopilot a mode of operation that
automatically manages the most complex
aspects of your infrastructure
configuration
if however
the user needs more control of their
clusters
she can choose a standard gke mode of
operation
you can think of modes of gke
as the level of control customers have
over a given gk cluster and the best
part yet you can mix and match most of
operation between different clusters
so you choose gke standard for advanced
configuration flexibility over the
cluster infrastructure or gk autopilot
to have google provision and manage
entire underlying infrastructure user is
in full control and can break glass
converting autopilot clusters into
standard
these are just a few examples of how
autopilot does
things differently
autopilot clearly wins as a hands off
kubernetes experience because it
optimizes for production like kubernetes
expert
provides strong security posture
lets google become your sre reducing the
day to operation improves resource
efficiency
and it's still kubernetes still gke
but
how does this all play into gke cost
optimization
gk autopilot shares a four-way
scalability capability with the gk
standard
same well-known tech as horizontal port
auto scaling or vertical portal to
scaling apply
and serve as a frame of cost reference
users are still in full control about
how their workloads will scale and
behave
however
the infrastructure is now managed fully
by the autopilot
and that has significant
optimization implications for everything
you plan to do with gke
remember early in the conversation we
talked about the four main challenges of
cost optimization
with autopilot you pay for the compute
resources requested with our new
pay-per-pot model paying for notes
remains a thing of the past
that means that pin packing is not a
problem anymore
how cool is that
not only do you get and manage hands-off
experience that lets you focus on your
business while improving your security
and operational posture you also get rid
of one of the most challenging aspect of
the cost optimization
and
if you thought this is not enough how
about not having to pay for the compute
overhead cost of running the os and the
cost of running kubernetes such as cube
system components
scalability
is a big subject we graduated 15k to ga
in 2021 which for the vast majority of
users removes scalability as a
constraint in cluster design
why does it matter
thanks to operating in one large cluster
you can simplify microservices lifecycle
management
easier absorb larger spikes in resource
demand and shorter the time to process
data for batch workloads as the result
you can combine the services of your
organization into one or just a few gke
clusters that provide better utilization
and in effect will cost less
combine this with our cost optimized
machine types such as e2 or tau for even
better price performance ratio compared
to general purpose vms next
is the node auto provisioning a feature
that is internally powering all of
autopilot
but what if you can't yet run autopilot
bean packing that annoying issue that
requires you to either
make sure your workloads
fit well inside of a machine site or
manually create and manage multiple node
poles and play with affinity that can
quickly get out of control and become an
operational bottleneck but there is a
simple option
configure node auto provisioning
node of the provisioning is the next
generation of our cluster rotoscaler
that not only knows to scale your
cluster using the chosen vm types but
also knows
to create entire node pools from scratch
that are best suited for your specific
workloads
none of the provisioning
makes gke clusters fully automatic
provisioning relevant machine types like
gpus and tpus and removing node pools
when not needed
node auto provisioning is also
integrated with vertical pod auto
scaling and provisions optimal node
pools ahead of vertical port auto
scaling updates to ensure quick action
in practice
that means that you're more likely to
have vms that are right size for your
workloads than what you get with the
manual provisioning
all right roman
those are my top three what about yours
thank you yes
i definitely have my own list as well
let me go through some of our latest
additions that we believe are important
for everyone to know and understand
we know that with autopilot and node
auto provisioning bin packing is a
non-existent or considerably smaller of
a problem but what about application
right sizing while app right sizing is a
challenging dimension to tackle we've
been making significant progress to make
it simpler for you
let's look at the latest preview for the
multi-dimensional potato scaling
horizontal potato scaler is a term that
is familiar to most or everyone using
gke
horizontal potato scaling scales your
pots horizontally adding replicas when
certain thresholds or conditions are met
hpa works hand in hand with class
rotoscaler or node.provisioner making
sure that resources requested by
containers can be accommodated on an
existing node
if this is not the case new nodes are
being added to the node pool however
that means that the users deploying
containers might
must have expert knowledge of the exact
amount of resources to be configured for
their workloads
based on what we know of how kubernetes
is used the right resource choice is a
true challenge the few mastered
this is why we've introduced the
vertical potato scaling a capability
that understands the true resource usage
of your containers and recommends or
directly adjusts the requests to get
them as close as possible to what your
containers actually need to operate
properly
however hp and vpa did not always play
well together as hpa had targets such as
cpu vpa had trouble understanding either
resources under consumption was a choice
or an effect
this is why we've introduced the
multi-dimensional potato scaler now in
preview with a single object gke can now
manage both horizontal and vertical
autoscaling
while hpe continues to add or remove pot
replicas based on cpu vertical but auto
scaling works on memory one of the most
overprovisioned resources to adjust it
to requests that meet best your
container actual usage needs
with this further simplifying the
upright sizing and the off-peak hour
over provisioning challenges
now what if we told you that you could
improve your gke cluster utilization
meaningfully with a single change
please meet the optimize utilization
profile now in ga
if your applications are ready to
tolerate a more aggressive cluster to
scalar behavior this is the feature to
try
the optimize utilization profile is the
second in line of our auto scaling
profiles giving users choice of a more
active auto scaling and scheduling
behavior
the well-known balance profile optimizes
for availability it scales down idle
notes only after 10 minutes workloads
are also spread as much as possible by
the scheduler
optimized utilization profile on the
other hand strikes a balance between
availability and cost efficiency
nodes scale down after one minute of
being idle aside scheduler tries to bin
pack pods from different deployments as
much as possible to add scaling down
speed and statistically maximize your
chances of having empty nodes that can
be easily removed
where it takes the balanced profile as
much as 10 to 30 minutes to scale down
notes after an abrupt stop in requests
it takes optimized utilization profile
one to three minutes to achieve the same
result
the way this is achieved is reducing a
number of intervals and thresholds that
increase the sensitivity of auto scaling
behavior to set load thresholds such as
scale down times delay after add and
scan intervals
in our tests optimize utilization
profile shows up as being one of the
capabilities that you could adopt for
significantly improved outcomes
we've now had a look at five great gte
features that help improve the balance
between cost and performance out of the
box
but how do you even know if anything
needs to be improved
and what is the scale of the opportunity
at hand
how do you help your team take a step
forward into solving for the cultural
challenges of gt cost optimization
i am thrilled to introduce the gke cost
optimization insights
now available in preview across all
regions and gke cluster types
gke cost optimization insights gives you
a single entry point into the gta cost
optimization journey right inside the
user interface
let's see how it works
let's start with a blank project and
create the first cluster
for this we will use the recently
released cost optimize cluster setup
guide the setup guide helps build a gke
standard cluster with all the best
infrastructure level cost optimization
features built right in
the cluster is now
created but how do we know where we
stand on the cluster resource usage
efficiency
with the new cost optimization tab
discovering this becomes a no-brainer
in one click we see all the key
information for the cluster such as used
requested or allocatable resources for
memory and cpu
cost optimization insights works across
standard and autopilot should you have
one or hundreds of clusters
let's add a number of other clusters to
see it better
now bin packing is not a challenge when
you use autopilot this is made very
clear in the view differentiating the
standard and autopilot clusters on the
type of metrics you should care about
in an autopilot cluster only the used
and requested resources matter while
with standard you should also care about
your allocatable capacity
spotting your cost optimization
opportunities out of the box has never
been easier and with the time peaker you
can even see the data across the time
horizon of your choice
cpu and memory aggregations in time give
you visibility of your cluster sizes and
running capacity at all
times clustering sites help spot bin
packing upright sizing and potentially
off-peak our optimization opportunities
but which of the workloads are the
largest contributors to resource
consumption
to help answer this you have now access
to cost optimization sites at workload
level 2.
let's deploy a number of workloads to
various clusters to see this in action
there are now multiple deployments
available
let's also top it up with one of the
offerings from the marketplace
as everything is deployed now within
moments we start seeing insights for
workloads such as used requested and
resource limits for each individual
deployment
with this new view understanding
application right sizing opportunities
becomes considerably less of a challenge
by looking at used versus requested
capacity all teams can keep an eye on
optimization opportunities for their
individual workloads
and that in turn helps with one more
cost optimization aspect building a
solid cost optimization culture across
your entire
team watch this space we're just getting
started and we're looking forward to
adding more capabilities that would
improve visibility and provide
recommendations for gke cost
optimization
that was it from my site jersey take it
from here
thank you roman and big thanks to our
audience for staying with us today
and remember
we're on a mission to empower you
to never again waste time and money on
infrastructure you don't actually use
so here's our call to action
if you're only getting started with gke
check forester total economic impact
report to see what impact gke may have
for your business
are you already deployed and going full
speed
follow the six things we discussed today
and see how this advances your gke
capabilities
have you already done all of this
come partner with us for more in-depth
collaboration get in touch with your
account representative or reach us via
media channels
if you want to learn more about gke cost
optimization follow these links
thank you
you